what is going on a buddy and welcome to
part 4 of zipline the local installation
back-testing and all that fun stuff see
tutorial series in this tutorial what
we're going to be doing is talking about
how we can set up a custom trading
calendar in order to trade in markets
that aren't necessarily the new york
stock exchange so first of all what I
want to do is like let's go into our
main zip line directory here go into
utils calendars and then in here we can
just pull up the nice calendar since
that's the one that is the default one
anyway so in here we can see that
there's all kinds of stuff going on here
they're pulling in holidays and more
holidays and then if we scroll on down
to here we can see what time early
closes if there is one we can see when
we open it's nine thirty one we can see
they close at 4:00 p.m. also we can see
the U at the time is us Eastern here
we're using some holiday information and
then regularly close on some other
random days ok so that is the trading
calendar that is by default the one that
is used now what if you don't want that
what if you're trading on a different
market well there's quite a few other
markets included here by default just in
your installation another probably
pretty close to what we are looking for
with like a 24-hour training calendar
would be the US futures which in this
case even though on quanto peein they're
not a 24-hour account calendar for some
reason from what i can visually tell
here
looks like they closed at 1800 and open
right back up at 1800 in one minute
therefore sounds like it's 24 hours not
really sure if they're doing something
else here but hmm anyway this is pretty
close but yeah if you wanted to trade us
futures great they also have the TSX
here the LSE they've got the CME so
they've got some other markets here but
I don't see like the Australian Stock
Exchange for example so so definitely if
if you have another market that you
wanted to trade you'd want to be able to
make a custom custom calendars so what
we're going to
do is I'm actually just gonna copy paste
here and I'm gonna call this file
exchange calendar and I'm gonna instead
call it calendar underscore 24hr so just
24-hour calendar now we're going to do
is I'm going to open it up in sublime
I'm gonna pull it on over here and this
is gonna be the calendar I'm actually
just gonna use the text base version of
this tutorial and copy and paste in the
code I don't really see why we would
write this all out ourselves so I'm
gonna just take this copy your paste and
what we have here is the 24hr it's a
training calendar type and then here's
the information very simple calendar
basically it opens at you know midnight
closes one minute before midnight and
repeats Monday through Sunday really
simple so that is our calendar that we
want to use so I'm gonna go ahead and
save that
I'm gonna close out of that again all
that code is in the text-based version
of the tutorial just like I said I don't
really see any value in us writing all
that out now what I want us to do is
talk about the data that we're actually
going to use so let me pull up the data
set that I'm going to use in this
example so like I've been saying in this
series if you've got a different data
set that you want to use by all means
use your own data set we're going to use
the BTC USD CSV file so that is trying
to find it see if I could pull it up
here we go so this is what that file
looks like so as you can see it's
actually in UNIX time and then it has
low high open close and volume data
great it's every minute data we can see
that every 60 seconds we have a new
value and all that so first what I'm
going to do is show you how I'm loading
this into a data panel because with the
quanto peon data we're relatively
comfortable and believing that that data
is pretty well maintained data but when
it's your own data or it's coming from
some other API and it wasn't built to be
used with the zip line backtester there
might be other things you need to think
about so I'm going to point some of
those out
so let's talk first about loading this
data in as soon as I find where I'm
trying to work and again all this is
code that you should be familiar with so
I don't see any value in us um
handwriting it out so first I'm just
gonna talk about the code so I'm gonna
copy and paste it in again so just go to
the text-based version of the tutorial
so so basically yeah we're just gonna
read it in
I need obviously these imports here but
that's okay I'm just not gonna run this
until we're done I read in the the
Bitcoin CSV I'm converting that time
that unix time to a date-time format we
are specifying that it is indeed UTC
timezone we set the index to the date we
drop that initial time column you don't
really have to do that but I'm just
gonna do it then I'm gonna resample by
one minute and you might be thinking
well why are you doing that this data
was already in 1-minute format well I'm
so glad you asked so so the reason why
we're doing that is like what if so like
for example this data is pulled from an
API in real time what if that API goes
down for a few minutes well there's
going to be a gap and so there's gonna
be at some point when we're trying to
simulate this training environment where
we're zip line is gonna be like okay
what was the price for this time and
then it's not gonna have a value and
then you're gonna break so what we want
to do is we want to ensure that this is
100% minute data so we're resampling to
one minute and if there is any nada
number information in certain gaps we're
gonna use a forward fill so if the
exchange goes down we're gonna say hey
that price was whatever the last known
price was it's just gonna flatline until
the exchange comes back online again so
hopefully nothing happens in that time
other than maybe if you were
experiencing slippage you might fill
orders or something like that but other
than that this seems to be the best way
to handle for that once we've done that
we're just specifying that data BTC is
again just low high open closed volume
doesn't need to be necessarily in that
exact order I just literally used this
list here and then put quotes around it
so that's why I just went without order
so from there we print the head we'd
actually don't really need to be doing
that
then convert it to a panel again if you
had multiple kind of tickers you you
could envision how you might actually
convert this to string formatting
iterate over it and all that but I'm
I've already showed you how to do that
in the last tutorial I'm not gonna do it
again so now let's talk about the actual
trading strategy that we might use and
in fact I think what I'll do is I'll
just copy and paste the full code up to
this point so I'm gonna copy paste that
in and in fact actually what we need to
do is first let's load underscore ext
zip line in and then we'll paste in the
code and now this is basically our
strategies just a simple moving average
crossover strategy no nothing really
serious here then we load in convert
data to a panel and then we run the
algorithm now we don't want to run this
on the new york stock exchange because
it opens and closes and has holidays and
bla bla bla bla bla Blee want to load in
via our own our own script so the way
that we're going to do that is first at
the very tippy top we want to import the
calendar that we want to use so I'm just
gonna let's just throw it right here so
from zipline utils dot calendar this is
dot exchange underscore cow I'll see you
it's like exchange let me see if I can
pull it up real quick this one it's a
long name to type so I don't feel like
it so from that calendar I want to
import it was 24h R so that's our
24-hour calendar object so just in case
someone forgot from five minutes ago
we're just going to edit this real quick
boom we're just importing that trading
calendar object so then once we've
imported that we're ready to use it so
down here in our run algorithm we're
just going to pass one more variable
here and that's going to be training
underscore calendar and that is equal to
there's a bunch of different things you
can do a lot of times you're gonna see
this get calendar and then you can
specify something like nice or something
like that if it was a registered
calendar in our case we didn't go
through registering a calendar because
not using a data bundle and otherwise
without that I'm not sure why you would
ever register one someone can let us
know why but anyways 24hr don't forget
it's a you you want it to be a calendar
object not like a pointer to the class
so don't forget to create the object
with the empty parms and we should be
good to go so with that let me let's go
ahead and run this and in fact let's run
this and make it much shorter so let's
do 325 let's go ahead and run that we
forgot our comma here run it again
great and we're off we should get
something pretty quickly I'm gonna say
perf not head so this will print out
when it's done and then we could graph
things again I don't see much value and
rewriting out graph code that you should
already understand this is percent
change basically it's just a long way of
doing it
and boom this that's the performance
over one day of minute trading the
simple moving average crossover of
Bitcoin using a custom trading calendar
of 24 hours now you might be wondering
hey what gives this is still daily I
thought we were doing minute data well
no matter what time frame you use the
performance data frame is returned to
you in daily values I don't think I
really like that I wish that we could
customize this but we cannot not easily
anyways I think there should be a
parameter like in here and say like
return daily or return I don't know data
frame equals daily or minute or
something or return time and you could
specify what granularity that time
should be because what they're doing in
the back end and zip line and I know
this because I tried to look into and
see if I could change it is they
resample your data frame now they're
doing that
probably because you if this like
especially if you did like years of
minute data that would be a rather large
data frame but not that big to be honest
and then the only issue would be if you
want to go graph that data frame if you
didn't resample sometimes and change the
cranial arity it would be a lot to throw
up to a graph and it would be kind of
lagging to your computer probably but it
is what it is it's daily data possibly
in the future I will show you guys how
you could go about changing
that because I really do think like this
is a perfect example I'd like to see the
intraday information there I mean even
if you don't log minute by minute cuz I
would be like what 60 times 24 a day you
know little points but for like one day
that's totally fine to throw up all that
information on one graph but you
wouldn't even have you could resample it
to five minutes before grant graphing it
you could resample it to one hour before
graphing it and so on so I kind of feel
like that might be the next part in the
series if I get to it but don't expect
it to be coming anytime soon if somebody
else wants to do it and post how they
did it that's great
I've seen a few things on you know on
github with requests and stuff like that
with it you know issues that people have
posted some solutions to do it I'm not
really sure the best way to go about
doing it but anyway you can just not
resample the data frame that's a good
start I just wouldn't recommend graphing
it right after but anyway that's it for
now that's how you can do a custom
training calendar in our case we just
did 24 hours but you could come up with
all kinds of ways you'd have you'd have
to get kind of fancy if you want to
simulate holidays and stuff like that
but there are people who have posted up
examples of all kinds of different
trading calendars so you might be a
little fine that someone's made one for
your use case but anyways hopefully you
guys enjoyed if you have questions
comments concerns suggestions whatever
especially if you have an answer for how
we can eat more easily change this to
minute this performance data frame to be
an actual minute
wait a minute oh no that's our panel
almost god I was like wait what's going
on
no anyway if we can change this to
minute data and more easily it's in the
run algorithm - I believe you just you
can even see there's like the code where
they resample it you could you could
just remove that I'm not sure that's the
best way to go about it I really think
you'd want to add one more parameter in
here that specified well what the
resample ought to be and then have it
just default today so I think that's
probably the way I would do it and then
I maybe submit a pull request for them
to change that but anyways that's it for
now if you guys have enjoyed this
content this kind of series and stuff
you can support it at Python programming
done at slash support this is my
full-time job and I get almost
from viewers like you that's all for now
I will see you all in another tutorial